et
bonjour delphine batho homerj beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
députée des deux sèvres coordinatrice
nationale de génération écologie vous
avez été candidate à la primaire des
écologistes vous avez depuis rallié
yannick jadot on va évidemment parler
tout ça on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale ont présenté par pascal
jalabert bonjour pascal du groupe evraz
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france d'abord l'actualité c'est
toujours la crise sanitaire delphine
batho 12 départements où le port du
masque élevé pour les écoliers ce matin
et les députés qui entament demain
l'examen du texte sur cette crise
sanitaire avec notamment la prolongation
du pass sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet
2022 vous voterez ce texte non je
voterai compte s'il n'est pas amendée ce
projet de loi en fait pose deux
problèmes un problème de
proportionnalité de mesures qui sont des
mesures lourdes qui sont des mesures
temporaires ce ceux dont ce que souligne
d'ailleurs lui-même le conseil
scientifique c'est à dire que ces
dispositifs n'ont pas à durer
éternellement dans le temps faute de la
prudence parce qu'on ne sait pas comment
la pandémie va évoluer ce qu'il peut y
avoir une nouvelle vague mais le 31
juillet 2022 c'est beaucoup trop loin et
le deuxième problème c'est un problème
démocratique majeur d'abord parce qu'en
fait ce projet de loi
légifère pour après la fin de la
législature actuelle et le quinquennat
actuel et que j'ai légifère pour la
période électorale et qu'en période
électorale pendant les échéances de 2022
toutes les décisions relatives à la
pandémie doivent être prises dans une
forme de consensus national et donc on
ne peut pas donner un chèque en blanc à
l'exécutif pour faire ce qu'il veut
quand il veut pendant cette période
démocratique extrêmement sensible ça
veut dire pour vous il doit s'arrêter
quand se passe à nous faire le
tout doit être sous le contrôle du
parlement donc il n'ya pas de raison
pour l'instant de remettre en cause la
date du 31 décembre 2021 qui est dans la
loi pour l'instant et nous avons le
temps avant le 31 décembre 2021
d'examiner avec l'avis du conseil
scientifique la situation sanitaire qui
sera celle du mois de décembre pour
prendre si nécessaire des mesures de
prolongation mais aujourd'hui elles me
paraissent totalement prématuré et elle
pose un problème démocratique oui la fin
des tests gratuits c'est une bonne
décision
pour les non
il ya des exceptions je suis comme vous
le savez il ya des il ya des exceptions
on doit on peut pas effectivement
éternellement être d'en être dans la
logique des tests des tests gratuits moi
je suis pour la pour la vaccination donc
là dessus je suis très bien avoir mis
fin au test gratuit pour les non
vaccinés pour oui peut-être après on
peut discuter à ce qu'il fallait le
faire tout de suite à ce qu'il fallait
laisser un petit peu plus de temps ce
que tout le monde souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse sortir du dispositif de passes
sanitaire dès que la situation sanitaire
le permettre avec brillance ce qui
inquiète les français en ce moment c'est
la hausse des prix de l'énergie bien
évidemment jean castex a dit qu'il
allait revaloriser le chèque énergie fin
décembre rien yannick jadot disait qu'il
fallait un chèque énergie de 400 euros
fait d'accord avec ça oui bien sûr s 400
euros ce qu'on n'a pas bien compris
c'est que ces 400 euros en plus de la
revalorisation de jean castex ou 400
euros tout en en plus
donc c'est g250
jusqu'à expliquer les choses nous sommes
dans la situation catastrophique dans
laquelle le soutenons nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui sur les prix de l'énergie
faute d'anticipation des gouvernements
précédents et de l'actuel et faute d'une
vraie politique de sobriété énergétique
et de transformation de la consommation
d'énergie qui passe par la décroissance
de la consommation d'énergie parce que
les logements sont mal isolés parce
qu'on n'a pas résolu toute une série de
problèmes on se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec des conséquences sociales majeures
et une dépendance extérieure de la
france qui est grave
ou qu'il faut des mesures d'urgence
sociale des mesures conjoncturelles pour
faire face à ses conséquences pour les
catégories les plus modestes mais aussi
pour les catégories moyennes un des
éléments de ce qui ne va pas dans ce
qu'a annoncé le gouvernement mais il
faut surtout des choix structurelles et
les choix structurelles c'est d'investir
massivement dans les économies d'énergie
pour protéger les ménages et protéger
les familles et aussi lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique dont qui a ses
400 euros pour les 5 millions de foyers
déjà concernés et ont eu pour les
classes moyennes qui ne sont pas
concernés
le chèque énergie c'est pour aider les
français à payer le gaz l'électricité
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour aider les
français à payer leur plein d'essence
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut les aider
à payer leur plein d'essence pour vous
il y à la nécessité de
prendre en compte ce que l'on appelle la
précarité énergétique liée aux
déplacements c'est à dire la mobilité
contrainte est un des leviers pour le
faire c'est le barème kilométrique
puisqu'en fait la plupart
moi je suis élu des deux sèvres donc je
connais bien les réalités d'un
territoire rural dans lequel tout le
monde prend sa voiture pour aller
travailler
on doit soutenir et développer le
covoiturage ça se fait d'ailleurs assez
naturellement mais on pourrait aller
beaucoup plus loin par toute une série
de dispositifs très pratique mais on
peut utiliser le levier du barème
kilométrique pour prendre en compte la
situation de ces français qui sont
dépendants de l'utilisation de la
voiture pour aller au travail ce
contexte un impôt de solidarité
écologique ou une taxe carbone hausse et
audible pour les français moi je l'écris
dans les débats récents de la primaire
écologiste je ne suis pas pour de
nouvelles augmentations de la taxe
carbone je suis pour le respect de ce qu
a porté la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui était de ne pas être dans
cette logique de l'inflation des taxes
et en ce qui concerne les taxes sur
l'énergie si on parle de l'électricité
et du gaz pour moi il faut ouvrir le
débat sur la baisse de la tva à 5 5% au
lieu de 20% sur les premiers
kilowattheures en fait c'est à dire sur
la part de consommation énergétique qui
est indispensable à chacun dans sa vie
quotidienne
que ce soit pour la lumière où que ce
soit pour le pour le chauffage mais dans
un certain niveau de consommation parce
que le but est pas d'encourager par une
baisse des taxes des consommations
énergétiques correspondant à des modes
de vie totalement énergivores mais juste
on va revenir sur l'énergie mais sur
l'essence vous n'êtes pas favorable à un
chaque essence vous pour vous ce n'est
pas la bonne solution il faut un
mécanisme sur de soutien aux françaises
et aux français qui subissent la
précarité énergétique chaque atelier à
la mobilité contrainte pour moi je vous
ai dit ça passe par le barème qui ne
l'ont pas cech récents je suis prête à
discuter d'autres d'autres dispositifs
mais ciblée sur cette population en
particulier rurale ou périurbaine qui
est dépendante de la voiture pour aller
au travail vous l'avez vu ce week-end le
retour des gis les jaunes sur certains
ronds-points moment c'est ce que ça vous
inquiète ce qui m'inquiète c'est c'est
la pauvreté qui
résulte de cette situation à laquelle
s'ajoute la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et à laquelle s'ajoutent londe
de choc delà de la pandémie dans notre
pays sur lequel on reviendra
certainement on va y revenir mais juste
sur l'ailé gilet jaune séné et on se
souvient de la flambée des carburants le
mouvement des gilets jaunes là ça repart
au moment où les prix de l'essence
augmente encore est ce que vous créez
une résine est ce que vous craignez une
résurgence de ce mouvement d'une manière
où je ne suis pas dans la crainte ce que
je constate c'est que le mouvement des
gilet jaune
exprimé avec force à la fois des
problèmes sur le prix de l'énergie mais
pas seulement avec aussi une
contestation du présidentialisme de la
vème république des inégalités sociales
qui a eu après ça un grand débat
national
donc rien malheureusement n'est sorti
malgré tout ce qu'avaient exprimées les
citoyennes et les citoyens qui a eu
derrière ça une convention citoyenne
pour le climat et que le gouvernement
actuel n'a rien trouvé de mieux à faire
que de s'asseoir sur les propositions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
et de leur tourner le dos donc je ne
suis pas surprise les problèmes n'ayant
pas été réglés qu'il y ait une nouvelle
expression de colère dans le contexte de
flambée des prix de l'énergie on va
parler du nucléaire oui le nucléaire
donc emmanuel macron mise sur ce qu'on
appelle le nouveau nouveau c'est à dire
des petits réacteurs au fou y at il
d'autres solutions quand on voit que
l'allemagne est obligée de rouvrir des
centrales à charbon pour combler le
déficit électrique en fait le
gouvernement est en train de raconter
aux français des fadaises des falaises
des fadaises de façon extrêmement simple
en fait quasiment les deux tiers de
l'énergie consommée en france sont des
énergies fossiles et nous devons
diminuer de 60 5% c'est-à-dire de façon
drastique
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
entre maintenant et 2030 du nucléaire
sera sa non non tout ce dont on est en
train est en train de parler le
gouvernement
les petits les petits réacteurs les op r
ça concerne 2035 2040
donc on est en train de se moquer du
monde ya une part de bluff en fait dans
ce dans ce qui est dit qu'il n'est pas
dans la réponse à ce qu'est l'état
d'urgence écologique et l'état d'urgence
sociale dans lequel nous sommes
vis-à-vis des problèmes énergétiques qui
est que ce qui compte c'est ce qui se
passe entre maintenant et 2030 et il n'y
a aucun autre chemin que celui de la
sobriété et de la décroissance de la
consommation d'énergie tout le reste
c'est des débats sympathique mais qui ne
sont pas sérieux le regard de l'état de
croissance comment vous allez expliquer
à l'ouvrier detremmerie en lorraine de
montbéliard chez still hantise de bosch
à rodez que demain ils seront plus de
boulot alors je ne vois pas pourquoi
demain ils auraient pu parce qu'ils font
des injecteurs diesel parce qu'ils font
des moteurs karbala
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire mais
les ouvriers de bosch à rodez ils sont
victimes de l'aveuglément de l'état sur
la question du diesel donc en fait c'est
le fait de ne pas avoir anticipé la
problématique du diesel qui conduit
aujourd'hui à des impasses industriels
ensuite de quoi on parle quand on parle
de sobriété énergétique on parle d'
isoler les logements on parle de
développer le train le ferroviaire les
transports en commun on parle du
covoiturage pour ce qui est de la
voiture on parle de voitures qu'ils
arrêtent d'augmenter emploi à consommer
toujours plus ce qui a effacé les
véhicules ont pris dix kilos par par an
depuis depuis 50 ans c'est à dire qu'en
fait tous les gains d'efficacité
énergétique des moteurs ont été effacées
par l'augmentation du poids des
véhicules et des suv donc de revenir à
des véhicules de moindre de moindres
volumes de moindre poids pour faire des
économies d'énergie la sobriété
énergétique c'est une politique
d'économie d'énergie ça veut pas dire
qu'on arrête d'économie de consommer de
l'énergie ni qu'on ferme les usines
concrètes contrairement la caricature
que vous venez de faire qu'est-ce qu'on
fait le nucléaire du coup le moi je suis
opposé à la construction d'un nouveau
parc nucléaire puisque c'est ce dont il
est question ensuite on peut débattre
par rapport au parc nucléaire existant
de des délais dans lequel on peut
diminuer la part du nucléaire et avoir
un horizon à long terme de sortie du
nucléaire ça plus loin ce livre est il
faut le regarder de façon pragmatique à
mesure qu'on fait des économies
d'énergie qu'on fait des transferts des
énergies fossiles vers l'électricité
et consorts des énergies fossiles donc
on peut le regarder de façon pragmatique
et privés à redon de dire puisque j'ai
été la ministre en charge de l'énergie
du nucléaire et de la sûreté nucléaire
que le nucléaire n'est pas une énergie
qui ne pose pas des problèmes
considérables ce sont des problèmes de
sûreté et de sécurité
d'autre part le nucléaire n'est plus
compétitif sur un plan économique
aujourd'hui on voit que le pm a
multiplié par 4 sa durée de construction
et à multiplier par cinq le coût de sa
construction et qu'aujourd'hui il ne
produit toujours pas d'électricité à
flamand il le réacteur repères donc
emmener le pays sans aucun débat
démocratique
parce que c'est aussi un problème dans
la construction d'un nouveau programme
nucléaire est une erreur et une faute
est une faute de méthode par rapport à
la démocratie était une faute par
rapport aux vraies solutions aux
problèmes énergétiques de la france qui
sont de réduire la consommation et de
sortir des énergies fossiles c'est aussi
une question d'indépendance est
importante et de faire monter le
renouvelable mais vous voyez les oui
bien sûr des français un jour c'est
encore la une aujourd'hui du journal
aujourd'hui en france les français écrit
son opposé à ces éoliennes alors il dit
sont favorables mais pas chez eux
comment vous faites face à ces
oppositions est ce que vous les
entendrez les merlons veulent ou
blanches je les connais bien ces
situations puisque je suis dans un
département rural celui des deux sèvres
où nous avons été très favorable au
développement de l'éolien dans un
premier temps les habitants les élus
locaux mais pas à n'importe quoi points
comme ni au développement anarchique de
l'éolien il n'est pas possible par
exemple que toutes les éoliennes de
nouvelles aquitaine se trouve dans le
sud des deux sèvres et donc je soutiens
aujourd'hui des habitants des mères qui
se heurtent à des projets dans lequel
leur avis n'est pas pris en compte qui
vont encerclé complètement des villages
ou qui vont construire des éoliennes en
rasant des bouts de forêt l'éolien je
suis à fond pour mais pas n'importe où
pas n'importe comment pas sans
planification territoriale est pas sans
débat démocratique et donc justement je
regrette que le gouvernement n'ait pas
entendu toutes les propositions que nous
avons fait à l'assemblée nationale pour
régler de façon méthodique c'est ces
problèmes et il l'a en fait en refusant
d'entendre le terrain il a nourri une
contestation globale de l'éolien qui est
dans l'erreur parce que nous avons
besoin de développer les énergies
renouvelables a fait des propositions
barbara pompe il ya quelques jours
justement pour mieux en train d en
encadrer le développement de ces
éoliennes ce sont les bonnes pour vous
il ya des choses intéressantes
j'attends de voir la concrétisation
puisque dedans il va forcément écouté il
ya des choses que j'ai proposé par
amendement à l'assemblée nationale
contre lesquels
refuser ou contout s'était déclarée
irrecevable donc j'attends moi je crois
ce que je vois j'attends de voir la
concrétisation
elle défend suffisamment l'écologie pour
vous aujourd'hui un marin pompier c'est
pas la question vous avez été ministre
de la transition oui mais en fait
difficile d'être mise et la transition
écologique
c'est difficile quand vous avez un
président qui et contre l'écologie un
premier ministre et contre l'écologie à
venir de l'économie et des finances
quelques contres l'écologie c'est à dire
que le bilan qu'il faut faire moi
j'avais été limogé du gouvernement
nicolas hulot
h&r oui nicolas hulot a démissionné
c'est qu'en fait une vraie politique de
réponse à l'état d'urgence écologique ne
dépend pas du seul ministre en charge de
ce sujet ça dépend de l'ensemble de la
politique gouvernementale ce que
j'appelle une politique d'écologie
intégral on va parler de la chasse parce
que oui la chasse aux traditions donc et
nous vous arrêter pour l'autoriser et en
même temps au sénat une pétition pour
dire pas de chance le mercredi quelle
est votre position là dessus
ma position c'est d'abord l'urgence dans
laquelle nous sommes en matière de
biodiversité
nous avons une destruction parce que
c'est pas une disparition d'un tiers des
oiseaux des champs en france les arts
étaient illégaux que vient de prendre le
gouvernement autorise
la mise à mort de 110 mille oiseaux
d'espèces sauvages
d'espèces protégées d'espèces dont parmi
elles certaines sont en situation
d'extinction donc c'est une décision
d'un cynisme absolument sidérant
absolument consternants on est sur des
pratiques de chasse très
près jaillir précise très cruel et il y
a dans notre pays un état de droit et de
voir un gouvernement de façon manifeste
s'asseoir sur des décisions de la
justice s'asseoir sur les décisions du
conseil d'état pour une logique est en
fait une logique totalement
électoralistes c'est pitoyable c'est
pitoyable alors les arrêter ils avaient
été annulés en août par le conseil
d'état et le gouvernement republier de
novembre oui c'est ça voilà la justice
ils seront annulés à nouveau oui c'est
une atteinte à l'état de droit sur la
pétition sur le site du sénat dont
parlait pascal c'est une pétition pour
interdire la chasse le mercredi et le
dimanche vous pourriez la signer cette
pétition moi je je trouve qu'on a un
problème
dans les déclarations qui a eu de la
part du président de la fédération
nationale des chasseurs lorsqu'il ya eu
des accidents
tu as répondu en gros le risque zéro
n'existe pas ça c'est pas possible parce
que normalement la fédération des
chasseurs auraient dû dire c'est
intolérable
nous ne pouvons pas accepter qu'il y à
des accidents et donc nous allons faire
la police chez nous et donc je ne suis
pas surprise qu'ils que monte dans la
société la demande qu'il y ait un jour
par semaine sans chasse parce que en
fait la fédération n'entend pas ce
qu'est la demande de la société de
trouver ça il est inacceptable que des
personnes puissent est victime d'un
accident de chasse dont vous pourriez
signer cette pétition pas je ne vais pas
regarder donc je signe jamais de textes
à la légère je comprends tout à fait
l'idée jeu faut que je voie le texte est
laissé aller sur le site du sénat on va
parler de la présidentielle oui la
présidentielle d'abord on peut être
petit parentis augis l'ati vous serez
candidate dans votre chair conscription
j'ai pas chez vous de faire des annonces
aujourd'hui je suis encore pleinement
dans dans le mandat actuel et ses
passions présidentielle il peut encore y
avoir des discussions et un accord à
gauche on voit le total de la gauche
dans les sondages qui n'est pas très
élevé et puis la dispersion des
candidats six pour ne parler que des
parlementaires
c'est pas la question principale
la question principale c'est que dans le
paysage des candidatures à l'élection
présidentielle tel que moi je le
constate
j'ai un profond sentiment d'un acronis
mme on a
le président de la république qui fait
campagne avec les moyens de l'état on a
bon les conservateurs qui veulent être
plus conservateur que les conservateurs
on a le nez aux racistes néo sexiste
des candidatures de la social démocratie
ou de la france insoumise qui viennent
là avec le même programme que les que
les années passées et ça a un côté pour
moi hors sol et l'enjeu pour les
écologistes c'est de faire revenir
l'élection présidentielle sur terre dans
le réel de ce qui est longue de choc de
la pandémie dans notre pays et de ce
qu'est l'ondé de choc de l'accélération
du réchauffement climatique ce qui me
frappe si vous voulez dans l'état du
débat aujourd'hui c'est qu'on fait comme
si on était dans le monde d'avant
d'avant le qu'ovide d'avant les
incendies qui ont eu lieu cet été les
inondations les catastrophes et donc
nous le travail que nous allons faire
avec yannick jadot c'est de remettre le
réel au centre du débat de cette
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
comme ça que l'on peut apporter au pays
une nouvelle espérance comment vous
expliquez net pour le moment ce ne sont
que des sondages mais n'être qu'à 7 %
dans les sondages est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il ya pas de désir massive
d'écologistes au pouvoir d'abord la
campagne commence commence tout juste
ensuite les écologistes viennent de
franchir une étape importante avec la
réussite de notre primaire qui a été
intéressante nous sommes la seule force
politique à avoir
présenté la culture du débat
démocratique du débat de fond du débat
qui n'est pas dans la dernière petite
phrase est une force une forme
d'abaissement en fait de ce que doit
être le débat démocratique dans notre
dans notre pays nous nous présentons à
l'élection présidentielle en équipe
autour du candidat qui a été investi
yannick jadot et donc ce travail
commence et je suis sûr parce que c'est
la tante des françaises et des français
qui savent ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est la tente aussi de la
jeunesse
je suis sûr que nous allons réussir à
lever en france une nouvelle espérance
votre
examen parce qu'il nous reste très peu
de temps on vous l'avait qualifié de néo
raciste comment vous expliquez lui sa
percée a suffit en fait j'ai envie de
faire les lui vous voyez moi j'ai envie
de parler de l'accident ce qui ne répond
pas à une partie de la colère des
français l'hexane certainement pas non
certainement pas et répondre aux peurs
des français parce que il ya des peurs
qui sont légitimes dans le contexte de
la pandémie dans le contexte de
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique donc c'est de ça dont il faut
parler et des réponses que nous
souhaitons y apporter pour répondre à
votre question auprès de yannick jadot
je vais particulièrement travaillé sur
la façon dont on doit aujourd'hui
organiser la sécurité nationale la
protection civile de la population dans
le contexte des effondrements de
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité et on en reparlera merci
beaucoup merci cinémato d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci pascal
[Musique]